within the last ten minutes the only way
to Sanibel Island Florida southwest
coast reopened
Irma cut off access along the Seneca
causeway to and from Miami and the
mainland ruined from the mainland during
the storm Kris Van Cleave made it across
earlier this morning Chris good morning
good morning people coming back are
gonna find a lot of debris debris is
everywhere across Santa Belle power
lines are down which means the power is
out there's still a lot of water and
when you come around a corner you may
find something like this large trees
that have come down completely blocking
the roads no power and you can't drink
the water but people are being allowed
to come back let's show you some video
of some of the heavy machinery we've
seen come in here they are starting to
clear some of these trees to try to make
the area passable for people again they
got winds around 57 miles an hour at its
peak so it appears that Santa Belle is
breathing a sigh of relief this morning
officials say they aren't seeing
catastrophic damage but with so many
trees down they can't rule out that some
homes have been damaged that said they
are welcoming people back in Fort Myers
they got higher winds and they got water
that was a big concern the water the
storm surge did not appear to be as bad
as first forecast but still many people
evacuated some 30,000 went to emergency
shelters the largest was the Germain
arena now write as hermas I wall started
to smack into Fort Myers that arena
started leaking from the roof we've got
some video of that we can show you there
were 5,000 or so people that had taken
shelter there it raised a lot of concern
but the building held and this morning
the curfew has lifted people are
starting to head back home thank you
very much Chris Van Cleve